[Musique]
c'est un grand pape qui disparaît avec
Jean XXII en 1958 la fumée blanche du
conclave annonça au monde l'élection du
cardinal rankalli au trône de
Saint-Pierre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on avait parlé d'un pape de transition
mais l'effet devait bientôt démentir
cette idée cet homme de 77 ans qui pour
la première fois bénissait la foule du
balcon de Saint-Pierre devait se montrer
l'un des esprits les plus Hardy qui est
jamais présidé au destinée de l'église
[Musique]
Hardy dans les gestes de la vie il
renoua à la prison de Régina Chelli avec
la très ancienne tradition de la visite
aux prisonniers on le vit au milieu de
1300 condamnés leur apporter espoir et
consolation
on le vit ouvrir au Vatican ces
appartements particuliers au cinéma et
se prêtait avec une extrême bonne amie
aux exigences de la technique des
tailles mineurs mais qui marque un homme
celui-là était un homme simple mais en
même temps un esprit audacieux
il reçu la plupart des chefs d'État le
général de Gaulle en 1959 s'entretint
longuement avec lui mais l'acte le plus
lourd de conséquence de son règne aura
été avec la réunion du concile
écumenique de donner à l'église une
impulsion nouvelle c'est cet homme c'est
ce pape qui disparaît aujourd'hui et le
monde entier s'incline devant ce grand
mort
[Musique]
et voici les images de cette fin
universellement regrettée au soir de ce
lundi de Pentecôte la foule romaine se
précède sur la place Saint-Pierre devant
la masse du palais de sixtain ou dans
ses appartements du dernier étage le
papagonisait depuis bientôt 92
sur le parvis la foule suivait la messe
en plein air mais personne n'ignorait
plus que la médecine s'était déclarée
impuissante devant le mal et que la
dernière heure était proche
dans la nuit qui tombait la fenêtre de
la chambre du pape s'éclaira il était
19h49 Jean 23 s'était éteint donnant sa
vie comme il l'avait dit pour l'église
pour le concile et pour la paix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la visite des souverains suédois à Paris
s'est brillamment achevé sur une soirée
de gala à l'Opéra le roi Gustave VI ça
donne fait la reine Louise haute du
président de Gaulle et souverain d'un
royaume qui n'a pas connu la guerre
depuis un siècle et demi renoue avec la
France des liens très anciens puisqu'ils
ont pour ancêtre direct le français
Bernadotte qui fut maréchal de Napoléon
1er c'est pourquoi à Pau les illustres
visiteurs ont rendu visite à la famille
toujours fixée au pays de leur insecte
madame Marie-Louise artigualas de Berry
dépourvu une petite cousine et Monsieur
Charles Bernadotte aujourd'hui gardien
du musée Béarnais et hier employé le
chemin de fer un cousin
[Musique]
nous deux étaient bien entendu au
premier rang de l'assistance qui
accueillait le roi Gustave et la reine
Louise et aux places d'honneur au
déjeuner faire au souverain
[Musique]
il devait tous ensuite rendre visite à
la maison natale du fondateur de
l'actuel dynastie suédois
[Musique]
c'est entre ces murs dans ce décor
rustique que se passe à l'enfance de
celui qui devait s'illustrer sur les
champs de bataille de la Révolution et
de l'Empire et finir sur un trône le
grand ancêtre français d'une des
dernières dynasties royales de notre
temps
[Musique]
à l'Elysée le général de Gaulle a reçu
la visite des présidents des républiques
africaines francophones après la
conférence au sommet d'Addis-Abeba les
chefs des jeunes États ont voulu avant
de regagner leur capital respective
conférés à Paris des résultats et des
perspectives de ses premières assises de
l'Afrique indépendante
[Musique]
pour plusieurs centaines de milliers de
Britanniques le Derby d'Epsom a été
l'occasion d'une garden party monstre
on aurait presque fini par oublier qu'on
était venu là pour assister au triomphe
de la race chevaline il est vrai
qu'avant même le départ de la course les
Anglais ne se faisaient pas d'illusions
ils étaient certains que le vainqueur de
la plus grande épreuve hippique de
l'année ne serait pas un de leurs
cheveux
français Realco était alors Dieu
imbattables et ils avaient raison
monté par Yves Saint Martin le petit
jockey miracle de l'écurie Dupré helkoz
est un musée comme un petit pou sur les
2400 mètres du derby terminant sa
promenade de santé avec six longueurs
d'avance
une promenade de grands Seigneur puisque
Realco a ramassé 50 millions sous ses
sabots dorés
Cadarache et désormais un nom important
d'enquipement nucléaire français sur
1400 hectares d'un seul bloc s'étendent
les installations du centre inaugurées
par Monsieur Gaston Palewski ministre
d'État ces Cadarache qui allaient de
piles qui seront les centrales
nucléaires de l'an 2000 produira le
plutonium nécessaire à l'industrie la
première de ces piles Pégase vient
d'entrer en service
[Musique]
Cadarache marque un nouveau pas dans
l'essor de l'industrie nucléaire en
France
[Musique]
incompréhensible accident en Allemagne
un hélicoptère de l'armée américaine
utilisée pour poser vos fêtes d'un
clocher neuf une croix de 400 kg à
soudain capoter sans raison apparente
alors que l'opération venait de se
terminer
rien explique pour l'instant la chute
verticale de l'appareil dont l'accident
dramatique a fait deux morts et un
blessé grave
[Musique]
Notre-Dame de Paris la cathédrale la
plus illustre de la chrétienté avec
Saint-Pierre de Rome a eu 800 ans cette
année sous ses voûtes vient de retentir
le TDM de Berlioz première des
manifestations qui marqueront ce 8e
centenaire
[Musique]
Notre-Dame c'est sans doute un de ces
émouvantes témoignages que nous a laissé
la fois du Moyen-Âge mais c'est aussi
800 ans de l'histoire de Paris et de
l'histoire de France
[Musique]
l'un des trois portails le portail de
Sainte-Anne évoque l'évêque Maurice de
Sully qui en 1163 décida de donner à
Paris une cathédrale digneudelle dès
lors Notre Dame devait participer à tous
les grands événements
sa construction n'était pas terminée
quand Saint-Louis y apporta la couronne
d'épines
[Musique]
au 14ème siècle enfin achevé elle
resplendissait de tout son éclat
Paris vaut bien d'une messe avait dit
Henri IV Notre-Dame fut donc le témoin
de sa réconciliation avec les Parisiens
et dans l'île de la Cité elle a paru
alors comme le symbole de la nation
réconciliée
[Musique]
le mariage de Louis XIV avec l'infante
marithérèse consacra la paix retrouvée
au Traité des Pyrénées tandis que le
peuple de Paris continuait de dérouler
ses longues processions à l'ombre des
tours déjà 5 fois centenaires
1789 Notre-Dame qui vit la bénédiction
des drapeaux de la garde nationale
faillit bien être démoli
sauvé mais détérioré il fallut 6
millions de francs d'alors pour la
rendre digne du sacre de Napoléon
[Applaudissements]
au milieu du 19e siècle le parvis était
encore étriqué par l'Hôtel-Dieu et le
bâtiment des enfants trouvés les
démolitions entreprises par le baron
Haussmann en quadrupler la surface et
les 40 mètres de la merveilleuse façade
y retrouvèrent la majesté que nous leur
connaissons violer le duc en fin lui
rendit sa flèche naguère détruite la
guerre de 1870 passa sans trop et
gratiné la cathédrale et en 1918 le TDM
de la victoire marqua la fin de la
première guerre mondiale
[Musique]
ainsi au cours des siècles le bourdon de
Notre-Dame n'aura pas cessé de rythmer
les heures graves ou joyeuses de
l'histoire de France
[Musique]
sur la place Saint-Pierre noir de foules
au milieu du déploiement d'un faste
Royal le pape Jean XXII a été conduit du
Vatican à la basilique qui pendant
quelques jours doit abriter son tombeau
[Musique]
coucher sur un lit d'apparaît à bras
d'hommes vêtu des ornements pontificaux
miroitant de pourpredor le pape défunt
entouré de gare de Suisse et de garde
noble semblait flotter au-dessus des
têtes innombrables de ce peuple qu'il
avait tant aimé et qui le lui rendait
bien
[Musique]
à l'intérieur de la basilique la
dépouille mortelle de Jean XXII devait
être placée sous le baldaquin de bronze
qui abrite l'hôtel de la confession
au-dessus de la tombe de la poutre c'est
là que pendant deux jours et demi il
recevra l'hommage public du monde
chrétien pendant ces 48 heures des
milliers des milliers de fidèles
défileront devant le cataphalt après
avoir attendu de zerze entière le moment
de sa genouillée devant celui qui fut en
même temps que l'esprit le plus
audacieux le cœur le plus simple et le
plus accessible
[Musique]
peu d'hommes auront connu un hommage
aussi universel avec Jean 23 un grand
pape vient de disparaître
[Musique]
la traversée de l'Atlantique par un
hélicoptère solitaire est un exploit qui
n'avait jamais été réalisé un
hélicoptère lourd de l'armée américaine
vient de combler cette lacune 35 heures
de vol l'ont conduit par le Canada le
Groenland l'Islande et l'Écosse jusqu'au
Bourget
là son périple devait lui valoir d'être
remarqué au milieu d'autres hélicoptères
aux performances remarquables comme le
désert Sikorski la gruevalente de
l'Allemagne de l'Ouest qui promène avec
la plupart faites aisance des camions
dans le ciel
l'aviation et l'espace tiennent en effet
salon ou Bourget le général de Gaulle a
inauguré cette grande manifestation à
laquelle participe 17 nations pour sa
part la France il y a dévoilé son futur
satellite ou voguera le successeur du
rail
[Musique]
le chef de l'État a pu admirer la
maquette de l'avion supersonique
franco-anglais Concorde dont les
États-Unis ont commandé sur plan 6
exemplaires
il a pu également assister aux
évolutions du Balzac
cet appareil français décolle et atterri
dans un mouchoir de poche
il peut rester immobile ou reculé en
plein ciel ce qui n'empêche pas de voler
à deux fois la vitesse du son
le 25e salon de l'aéronautique est
ouvert dans ce supermarché de l'aviation
la France vient une des premières places
aucun Mailly la vedette a été tenue par
la mx30 version française du chat
européen de 30 tonnes armée d'un canon
de 105 qui rentre avec une très grande
précision un obus à charge creuse
capable de percer tous les blindages la
mX 30 d'une très grande mobilité
franchite avec aisance un obstacle
vertical de 90 cm un fossé à bord franc
large de 3 mètres le laisse indifférent
ajoutons que sa parfaite étanchéité lui
permet de traverser les rivières par 2
mètres de fond voire 4 mètres avec un
équipement spécial comme aussi de
continuer de manœuvrer en zone
contaminée en cas de conflit atomique
à l'heure des fusées opérationnelles à
tête nucléaire la mx-30 permet au char
blindé de demeurer une arme de combat
fondamental
il flottante bouée laboratoire on ne
sait trop comment nommer cette étrange
champignon fiché dans la mer en rade de
Villefranche et sur lequel un
hélicoptère a récemment amené à ministre
cette construction dans le commandant
Cousteau et le promoteur et qui a
inauguré monsieur Gaston palevski
ministre délégué à la recherche
scientifique est actuellement unique au
monde
elle est composée d'un long tube
vertical contenant 4 étages de
laboratoire et s'enfonçant jusqu'à 52
mètres de profondeur ce qui rend
insensible au plus forte houle de la
Méditerranée sa partie supérieure qui
domine la mère de 10 mètres et qui
renferme le laboratoire des
enregistrements un ascenseur descendant
jusqu'à quelques 25 mètres au-dessus du
niveau de la mer conduite aux quatre
laboratoires où seront étudiés la
biologie sous-marine la température et
la constance des courants et ce qui
était jusque-là impossible avec un
navire océanographique observez tous les
phénomènes de l'océan d'une manière
continue et à un point donné en effet
cette bouée permet des prélèvements
continuels d'échantillons d'eau à tous
les niveaux et l'observation directe de
la vie de la mer par les vins hublots
répartis sur sa surface immergée
l'équivalent si l'on veut d'une station
météorologique mais au cœur de l'océan
[Musique]
envahi par le torrent formé par des
pluies incessantes la grotte de
foussoubi laisserait-elle ressortir les
cinq spéléologues qui s'étaient
aventurées sous ses vœux malgré les
pompes malgré les travaux d'entreprises
pour détourner le torrent restaient-ils
après 5 jours d'absence une possibilité
de sauver les captives de la grotte art
des choix
le torrent est un enfin détourné les
sauveteurs purent s'enfoncés dans la
montagne avec leur scaphandre et leurs
canaux pneumatiques
fin de l'épreuve triste fin d'ailleurs
car si derrière Émile Chayette le
premier des rescapés remontait deux de
ses compagnons deux autres ne
reverraient plus le soleil de l'un de
ceux-là on ne remontrait qu'un cadavre
de l'autre on ne retrouverait aucune
trace
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rien ne semble désormais impossible à
l'athlète français Michel JAZY qui va
les record du monde sur commande et le
miracle dans tout cela c'est que jazine
n'a rien à Superman jazzy c'est monsieur
tout le monde avec un petit quelque
chose en plus c'est-à-dire le cran et le
désir de vaincre le tout saupoudré d'un
grand amour pour l'athlétisme cela
suffit parfois pour devenir un très
grand champion c'est presque la fin de
cette tentative contre le record du
monde du 2 mailles au stade Charléty il
passe il résistiblement son partenaire
Robert Baugé se finit chez désormais
l'une des qualités essentielles de
Michel JAZY qui pourrait croire en le
voyant sprinter qu'il est en train de
battre le record du monde des 2000
l'allure d'un spécialiste du 400 mètres
on ne sait pas jusqu'où ira Michel JAZY
sûrement vers un titre olympique l'année
prochaine
le deuxième Salon International de la
chasse photographique qui s'est ouvert à
Paris révèle un aspect nouveau de la
chasse
un chasseur il ne s'agit plus de tuer
les bêtes mais de les surprendre et de
les restituer vivantes sur une photo ou
sur un écran
[Musique]
mais remplacé par l'objectif d'une
caméra la carabine de précision ne fait
pas de cette chasse nouvelle un sport
mineur
[Musique]
il faut comme à l'autre de la patience
de l'habileté du courage et du
sang-froid
mais quelle joie aussi de rapporter des
tableaux de chasse vertigineux comme
l'ont fait Jacqueline et François sommer
de promoteur de ce nouveau sport un jour
en même temps que les girafes vous
pouvez découvrir les rites secrets de la
vie des autruches
un autre jour vous découvrez à bout
portant pour ainsi dire le plus
extraordinaire tableau vivant de la vie
de famille des éléphants
chasseur changez donc votre fusil
d'épaule il ne s'agit plus de tuer de
pauvres bêtes mais de les ramener vivant
le voyage du général de Gaulle à travers
les Charentes et le Poitou a commencé
par cognac ou monsieur Félix Gaillard
ancien président du conseil à accueilli
le président de la République mais c'est
le premier résistant de France qui va se
recueillir devant le monument de
Chasseneuil qui garde la mémoire du
maquis du Sud-Ouest
d'Angoulême à Royan à LA ROCHELLE à
NIORT à Poitiers le général de Gaulle a
évoqué avec les grands problèmes de leur
celui de sa succession il faut a-t-il
dit que les Français ne recommencent pas
à suivre les clans qui les portent à se
diviser rien ne peut aller contre les
faits il n'y a jamais eu entre nous
autres choses qu'un accord profond sur
le grand destin de la France
une tempête se coule en glaire depuis
que le ministre de la Défense monsieur
profumo marié à une actrice de Renaud
Valery Hobson avoué en donnant sa
démission qu'il avait menti le scandale
s'est répercuté dans le monde entier
d'autant plus qu'il se complique d'une
possible à faire d'espionnat
à son domicile monsieur profumo avait
démenti devant la presse comme il
l'avait fait à la Chambre des communes
toute relation particulière avec un
mannequin professionnel Christine Keller
qu'un récent scandale venait de mettre
en vedette
[Musique]
le ministre l'avait connu chez le
docteur Ward médecin traitée qui
réunissait chez lui une société aussi
élégante que mélangée le docteur Ward
est aujourd'hui arrêté sous l'incubation
de proxénétique cette affaire avec la
bouste le gouvernement de Monsieur Mac
Millam qui après les aveux de Monsieur
profumo a trouvé même dans son parti une
atmosphère houleuse l'affaire Christine
Keller fera-t-elle tomber Mac Millam et
perdre le pouvoir aux conservateur
[Musique]
aux États-Unis la crise raciale qui
sévit dans la Lama semble avoir fait
revivre les rites d'un temps qu'on
croyait à Bonnie on a revu flamber les
croix du Ku Klux Klan
nouveau développement à tous kalosa un
délégué spécial du président Kennedy a
dû réclamer en application des lois
l'entrée de l'université interdite à
deux étudiants noirs dressé devant la
porte le gouverneur Wallace a refusé
mais le gouvernement fédéral avait fait
passer sous ses ordres les forces
locales et c'est le commandant de ses
forces qui réclama l'application de la
loi
sous cette pression Wallace s'inclina
c'est ainsi que les deux étudiants noirs
James Wood et Miss Viviane Malone ont pu
entrer à l'université victoire pour
Kennedy mais le soir même Edgar everse
leader de la cause noire était assassiné
à Jackson rien n'est encore fini
[Musique]
le Grand Prix de Paris préoccupe déjà
les turfist certains se livrent de
savants et harassants
d'autres s'en remettent au hasard pour
désigner le cheval sur lequel il
miseront
il en est qui veulent multiplier leur
chance et achète un billet de la tranche
spéciale de la Loterie Nationale
particulièrement tentante il faut
l'avouer avec les lots de 2 millions 1
million un demi million
d'autres encore font appel à des
spécialistes très avertis pour établir
leur Paris
pendant que de petits malins se
renseignent à des sources on ne peut
plus autoriser que dire en conclusion
sinon bonne chance à tous
[Musique]
une nuée d'insectes de métal s'est
abattue sur le terrain du Bourget le 25e
salon de l'aéronautique s'achevé par la
grande parade habituelle des ailes et
des rotors
l'individualisme y a trouvé des sujets
de satisfaction avec la bicyclette du
ciel d'abord
avec le dispositif individuel de
sustentation parfait ensuite
parmi les avions des nouveautés le
Bréguet Atlantique apparaît de
reconnaissance maritime construit par 5
pays de latin
les deux tranches fruits de la
collaboration franco-allemande avion
cargo biturbo propulseur qui vole à 500
km heure
l’impressionnant Vulcan MK2 est un
bombardier supersonic anglais à 4
réacteurs
le mystère vin lui pire et acteur qui
vole à 850 km/h répond à un tout autre
objet capable de transporter 8 à 18
passagers c'est un appareil d'affaires
et de petits transports très rapides
le mirage 4 à elle Delta compte parmi
les bombardiers actuels les plus rapides
plus de deux fois la vitesse du son
[Musique]
quant aux appareils à décollage vertical
ils étaient deux à se disputer les
faveurs du public soudain l'anglais le
rocker allait manquer son atterrissage
et tomber brutalement de sa mère
le français Le Balzac effectuait
totalement sa démonstration de sur place
avantage sur le Hawker il dispose de
huit réacteurs de sustentation au lieu
d'un
alors où les Russes regardaient en l'air
pour tenter d'apercevoir le Vostok de la
première femme du cosmos les Parisiens
ont pu voir dans le ciel du Bourget
évoluer les 250 appareils les plus
modernes de notre temps
prépare pas n'importe comment conduire
après de 200 de moyenne pendant 24
heures ce n'est pas une mince affaire
sur un circuit somme toute assez
difficile tous ces virages le Tertre
Rouge mulsan Arnage Maison Blanche c'est
la bête noire des pilotes Gérard Laurent
l'un des champions de l'écurie René
Bonnet nous invite à reconnaître les
difficultés du parcours avec lui
troisième
[Musique]
ment
à l'intérieur
complètement
[Musique]
sur la gauche
déporté à ras de merde
et maintenant c'est le grand départ 49
voitures devant les stands et comme
toujours l'anachronique départ en course
à pied les moteurs ne sont pas encore
chauds que déjà on appuie à toutes les
champignons pour chaque pilote le
problème numéro 1 se dégageait le plus
rapidement possible de la meute il faut
éviter à tout prix les accroches cette
année la vedette numéro 1 de la course
et la Rover BRM à turbine numéro W0 elle
tourne pour la gloire puisqu'elle ne
participe pas au placement elle tiendra
jusqu'au bout à 173 de moyenne la
Ferrari numéro 10 de Rodriguez perd bien
vite elle aussi ses illusions après
avoir été la première il est vrai
abattre le record du tout et puis c'est
le début des émotions fortes avec
l'accident de maçon qui s'est retourné
après un dérapage
mais la rente continue avec la
macératine numéro 2 toujours en tête pas
pour longtemps cependant
[Musique]
ensuite ce succède en cascade on glisse
sur cette piste comme sur du verglas
et les serveurs des bolides bourré
d'essence jusqu'à la gale ont parfois
débordé par ce ment la route de plaques
dangereux
c'est un véritable jeu de massacre les
uns après les autres la plupart des
pilotes perdent le contrôle de leur
voiture tout cela n'empêche pas la ronde
de continuer se prendre
le bilan il est là sous vos yeux le sort
cependant épargner la majorité des
conducteurs sauf un le Brésilien
bino-ims tué dans sa voiture qui a
flambé sur 49 voitures au départ il n'en
reste plus que 13 à l'arrivée
et c'est la Ferrari numéro 21 des
Italiens scarfiote qui gagne l'épreuve
elle franchit la ligne d'arrivée suivie
d'une grappe de 5 autres Ferrari les
grandes triomphes cette année des 24
Heures du Mans 6 voitures en tête le
record battu à 190 de moyenne la grande
marque italienne est décidément
imbattable dans les épreuves d'endurance
pour voiture de sport
[Applaudissements]
qui serait le successeur de Jean 23 les
80 cardinaux venus du monde entier
allaient les lire dans le secret du
contrat parmi eux le cardinal Montini
archevêque de Milan bien connu souvent
cité son nom n'était qu'une silhouette
au milieu dos
et avec la parade traditionnelle les
rites de la clôture se déroulaient après
l'extra homeness qui fait des membres du
Sacré Collège autant de prisonniers
dehors sur l'immense place Saint-Pierre
la foule allait attendre caméra braquet
téléphone prêt à transmettre les
nouvelles au monde entier l'apparition
de la fumée noire si l'élection n'était
pas faite blanche si le pape était élu
deux fois elle fut noir la troisième
était blanche
[Musique]
et voici qu'au balcon de Saint-Pierre
apparaissaient le cardinal Octavia qui
allait annoncer le nom du nouveau pas
[Applaudissements]
sur l'ouverture de la lodgia se dessine
une mince forme blanche que la foule
remet à clams Jean-Baptiste Montigny est
maintenant le pape Paul VI
262E successeur de Saint-Pierre
[Musique]
l'anniversaire du 18 juin devant le
mémorial de la France combattante au
Mont Valérien a revêtu la simplicité et
le recueillement désormais traditionnels
le général de Gaulle est venu comme
chaque année au milieu de ceux qui
furent ces compagnons ranimer la flamme
qui brûle devant la crypte ou 16
résistance sont ensevelies 23 ans
aujourd'hui depuis l'appel du général de
Gaulle alors si inconnu si solitaire
mais qui donc a oublié
[Musique]
d'un voyage de 10 jours au cours
desquels il passera par l'Allemagne
l'Irlande l'Angleterre et l'Italie le
président Kennedy a été accueilli à
Cologne par le chancelier de Noé
[Musique]
on l'a dit un voyage dont la
signification politique est pratiquement
à moindrie du fait que le chancelier de
Noël va laisser la place à Monsieur
Eyrard que Monsieur Mac Milla met pour
ainsi dire condamné et que le
gouvernement italien est un gouvernement
de transition
[Musique]
chance de ce voyage n'est pas très
profond l'accueil de l'Allemagne au
président des États-Unis n'en a pas
moins été très chaleureux c'est au
milieu d'une foule que la police avait
peine à contenir que le président
Kennedy a gagné le cœur de Cologne pour
l'Allemagne de l'Ouest c'est un effet
une nouvelle garantie de sa sécurité que
vient affirmer la visite de Kennedy
le retour à Moscou des deux cosmonautes
du vol de Vostok 5 et Vostok 6 a été
plus encore peut-être que les précédents
l'occasion d'un triom à l'aéroport
d'abord où Valentina tereschova et
Valérie bicovski ont été accueillis
affectueusement par Monsieur cochon et
les plus hautes personnalités
soviétiques
au milieu d'une foule considérable les
deux héros du cosmos entourant monsieur
kontchav ont ensuite gagné la place
Rouge ou la population moscovite s'était
rassemblée en grand nombre
[Musique]
de la tribune d'honneur monsieur kruchev
au milieu d'un délire de ration présenta
les deux cosmonautes Bukowski qui a
battu tous les records de durée dans le
cosmos avec 82 révolutions en 5 jours
moins 6 minutes Valentina tereshkova la
première femme de l'espace
[Musique]
dans chaque cité on a créé des
installations souvent considérables pour
assurer la purification et le contrôle
de l'eau c'est qu'elle mettent à l'abri
des maladies épidémiques des dizaines
des centaines de milliers de
consommateurs quotidiens des
spécialistes ont même la charge d'un
apprécier le goût ce qui n'empêche pas
les citadins de faire quand même la fine
bouche mais c'est tout est saine même si
sa saveur est discutable
[Musique]
viens après cela l'heure des vacances le
citadin qui a loué une charmante maison
dans un charmant village ne peut
résister au romantisme du Puy ou dors
une eau si claire si fraîche si
naturelle
du moins le croit-il faute d'avoir fait
la relation entre le spectacle du
voisinage et l'effet des infiltrations
dans le sol et c'est ainsi qu'on
constate toujours après les vacances une
recrudescence de tifoïde car rien n'est
plus trompeur qu'une eau fraîche et
limpide il suffit de la regarder au
microscope
dans un village sans adduction d'eau
remettez-vous-en donc à l'appareil
purificateur house on
mais si vous êtes campeur et tenté par
l'eau d'une source qui chante au creux
des rochers il n'est bien sûr pas
question d'apporter toute une
installation de purification
voici alors une recette dont
l'application est des plus simples
quelques gouttes d'eau de javel dans 10
litres d'eau
agité avec un simple bâton de bois
conservé soigneusement propre
laissez reposer une demi-heure pour que
le chlore et le temps d'agir vous pouvez
boire alors avec tranquillité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
amateur de vieilles fermes de bois et de
ruisseaux dites-vous que les charmes de
la nature ne sont que ce qu'ils sont ne
gâchez pas vos vacances par un accès de
romantisme inconsidéré la civilisation
de l'eau de javel a du bon
[Musique]
il y a 30 ans grâce à Jean Mermoz la
route de l'Atlantique Sud est ouverte à
bord de l'arc-en-ciel Mermoz réalisait
dans les deux sens la liaison aérienne
entre l'Afrique et l'Amérique du Sud
mais c'était plus qu'un exploit sportif
qu'il avait réalisé il inaugurait la
ligne commerciale qui de Toulouse par
Casablanca Dakar natal et Buenos Aires
menaient jusqu'à Santiago du Chili
30 ans après cette aventure triomphale
de l'aérocostal ce n'est pas sans
émotion qu'on peut retrouver aujourd'hui
dans les sables du désert mauritanien
près de porétienne les restes du hangar
qui servit à Mermoz retrouvé aussi le
Guide mort qui servit d'interprète à
l'aviateur dans ses contacts avec les
hommes bleus
trouver encore non loin du hangar le
poste rudimentaire ou Mermoz et ses
compagnons s'enfermaient pour passer la
nuit à l'abri des coups de main
mais autour de ses souvenirs que de
changement des villes viennent de
pousser dans le désert camsado au bord
de la mer Zouerat dans la région de
fort-bouraud au pied de la montagne de
fer c'est d'ailleurs ce faire qui a tout
transformé se faire de la clé Diabi Jil
qui a folle les boussoles des équipiers
de Mermoz
un important complexe minier assure
maintenant l'exploitation à ciel ouvert
du minerai qui avec 66% de teneurs et
l'un des plus pures du monde
[Musique]
le président de la République Islamique
de Mauritanie et Monsieur Triboulet
ministre de la Coopération ont inauguré
la mise en service de ces gigantesques
mines dont on évalue les réserves à 200
millions de tonnes ils ont assisté au
chargement du train de 135 wagons
capable de transporter en un seul voyage
dix mille tonnes de minerais jusqu'à la
mer distante de 650 km
trois ans plus tôt il n'y avait rien ici
que le sable arrive aussi l'événement
a-t-il pris une allure de fête autour
d'un échoui gigantesque de 320 moutons
et dans l'allégresse générale les hommes
du désert firent tonnèrent aux
traditionnels festin tout morceau de
mouton fut de bonnes prises
[Musique]
le train de minerai cependant achevêt à
kansado son voyage de 650 km au port
minéralier tout neuf ou attendait déjà
les premiers transports
[Musique]
au bord de l'Atlantique fonctionne
aujourd'hui une immense chaîne
ininterrompue créée en trois ans pour
approvisionner en minerai les aciéries
de Dunkerque et d'autres en Belgique
dans la roue en Angleterre et en Italie
le minerai de fer est en train de
révolutionner le désert qui fut le
témoin de l'épopée de Mermoz
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]